Bonjour and hello everyone can I see a
show of hands who here things
chocolatine when they see this picture
alright and who thinks that's very
clearly upon show Paulo alright alright
so thank you for a very first survey
here and now that we have so very
clearly separated the heathen from the
civilized ones we can move on to less
controversial topics when we started all
of this we had one question in mind what
are the biggest frustrations for web
developers and designers today and I
wish answering that was as easy as the
survey that we just did spoiler alert
it's not well Before we jump into that a
quick intro first so this is CSS grade
CSS grid is a web platform feature that
allows developers and designers to
layout the page in two dimensions
instead of just one this was the case
with floats and flexbox and this project
that I'm going to talk about it started
shortly in 2017 shortly after CSS grid
was released and CSS grid was a massive
success so in Mozilla developer
relations team we asked ourselves how
can we support that more how can we get
more of these wins and how can we yeah
how can we repeat that so CSS Square was
a success because addressed the real
user need and it shipped in all the
browsers and roughly the same time and
came with tooling again in case of
Firefox for the great inspector and then
was seriously awesome that's that CSS
grid was literally years in the making
and layout had been an issue for
developers at least since the times we
we abuse tables for for to implement our
or layouts resident 90s so looking at
this we had a few questions when it's
when why did it take until 2012 to even
start addressing that problem
it was very obviously a problem even
before that and why did it take until
2017 to ship something and how was this
coordinated for shipping at roughly the
same time because most other things are
not and what were the roadblocks and
what were the things that were pivotal
to moving this forward so we took a step
back to see what the whole process
looked like from Mozilla's perspective
and after interviewing numerous people
involved in the process we identified
three distinct phases there is research
there's standardization and
implementation and there is adoption now
as you can probably tell immediately
this is a very simplified version that
really smooth this out many things and
this looks like a pipeline when in
reality it's more like a loop or a loop
of loops that look back on themselves I
mean you get the idea but this was good
enough for us to get started no most of
us had a pretty good idea about the
adoption side of things because that's
really where I'm the insurance and we
had some idea about the standardization
of implementation phase but we wanted to
know more about the research part of
this so how do we learn about developer
pain points what they need and what we
should prioritize for the web platform
so we interviewed more than 10 people
involved in different stages of that
process and it became clear that there
was no formal research really if Muslim
we have an amazing team that does use a
research for Firefox but that's for end
users and that's so much the case for
when it comes to developers we
don't have those resources and it's
important because at the place like
Mozilla I said we do have limited
resources so we can't go after
everything then just throw everything at
the wall and just see what sticks there
are some serious opportunity costs that
we have to pay when we decide to do
something because it usually means that
we cannot do something else at the same
time and this is what we heard from
people about how things are prioritized
so when we talk to two people involved
in this process at Mozilla like we
haven't tried formal research like it's
all ad-hoc but one thing stood out
because every single one of them said
the same thing here we need to hear more
from developers they really stood out to
us it makes so much sense because none
of us can be really successful without
that part without having that it's hard
to prioritize the right things without
knowing about developer pain points and
it's hard to find the right solution and
it's hard to get people to adopt
something that doesn't solve their
problem or doesn't solve the problem in
the right way so for all of these
reasons we proposed a developer needs
assessment what is that exactly
it's a prioritized list of web designer
and developer needs it's a single and
simple tool for harsh prioritization
across a massive feature space and
extremely diverse populations it's
published on MBN it's not owned by a
single browser vendor so we initially
proposed this under the umbrella of the
MDM product advisory board where we have
representation from browser vendors but
also from the w3c and industry
stakeholders because you know as a
community we have to have at least a
common understanding of the facts when
it comes to developer pain points the
developer needs even if you draw a
different conclusion
from them and finally it's reproduced
annually and this is important as an
industry we need to know whether we are
addressing developer pain points and to
understand whether we are prioritizing
correctly we need to track things like
like their needs and pain points over
time so we can see the impact of our own
efforts so that's what we need to do
this regularly and not just once and if
you do this well we think the MDM web to
open its assessment or mdn web DNA for
short we think that it can be a voice of
designers and developers working on the
web but as I said asking developers and
designers about their needs and
frustrations is not trivial the problem
space is really vast and the audience is
extremely diverse so let me tell you a
little bit about the process we went
through for that and I'll make that
short but and I already apologize up
front because I'm not a researcher we
worked with a very talented Ellison make
key from pinpoint research to design the
the for the research design and to also
conduct this I'll do my best to channel
her here yeah I'm not a researcher so in
January this year we started this
process by fielding a survey to our
production advisory board and we asked
them for data that they would use for
decision-making as part of their
planning process and we then had almost
20 in-depth interviews almost one hour
long interviews each with web developers
from around all around the globe and we
did that before putting the initial
version of the survey together and
that's important that's because we
wanted the survey to be rooted in the
voices of developers and designers from
the get-go because if we had run with
with what browser vendors wanted the
questions would have been based on the
internal perspective of browser vendors
by conducting the interview
we made sure to derive the survey
questions from the stories of developers
and designers what was important to them
in their work but also what caused them
frustrations and so to go from interview
findings to the surveys you follow up in
points analysis process going from
observations that's what we heard and
saw to insights what it means really two
critical themes that's what matters and
we're continuing that process to
incorporate the survey findings into
what we learned from the pilot
interviews so in practice that means we
transcribed 16 hours of interviews we
then coded them and we finally bucketed
them to derive insights for the items in
our survey that's a very hands-on
approach but based on these themes we
constructed this central survey question
around the frustrations of developers
and designers we then continue to work
with our product advisory board on the
overall survey but pilot interviews
where we watch multiple people or take
the survey at every iteration to really
ensure that survey questions would be as
unambiguous as possible and with the
help of more than 30 stakeholders from
various and the MPA be member companies
we have put together the final version
of the survey and was fielded in July in
August of this year we feel it around
the end but not just on mdn also through
the channels of a product advisory board
members there's a w3c that Google
Microsoft Samsung and poke through we
didn't do that just in English we
localized a survey into eight languages
that's Arabic simplified Chinese English
French Japanese Korean Brazilian
Portuguese Russian and Spanish I'm very
happy to announce that after fielding
the survey for four weeks more than
76,000 people took us up on on it and
more than 20,000 developers completed
the full 20 minute survey and that that
was in 173 countries total so just for
the completed complete responses alone
that's more than 10,000 hours of time
contributed by the community to help us
understand what their pain points and
needs are and we believe that makes the
mdn web DNA the biggest web developer
and designer focused survey so ever
conducted and with that scale come
benefits so we can segment that data by
experience level developer role country
satisfaction and we still can get useful
information out of that
so after this intro you might be
interested in the actual results yes I
mentioned we had participants from 173
countries across the globe but of course
that's not uniformly distributed so you
can see that just six countries here
make up more than half of the
participants and it's the US China
Russia India Germany and France it's a
little bit surprising because they
didn't even translate the survey into
German yeah that said we still have a
pretty good representation from Europe
Asia and North America but especially
with Africa we can really do better
hopefully next time where we just got 2%
of our responses this year so one
segmentation we were interested in was
developer types so there is this there's
of course the classic split between
front and back end but recently people
have started talking about front of the
front end and like back off the front
end there is no generally understood
term for this we really try to find one
so in the end we asked whether people
used primarily JavaScript on the front
end or CSS and HTML that's what most
people understood and it 6s expected
given our audience only a small number
of people saw themselves as back-end
developers and yet curiously and even
split between mostly and even split
between JavaScript and CSS plus HTML but
we had way more people considering selfs
full stack developers in terms of
experience or industries of course
growing at an incredible pace
so it shouldn't be too surprising that
one-third of all participants had less
than three years of experience and
almost two-thirds of all participants at
five years of experience or less and
speaking about representation from
previous surveys who were aware that we
would have to make an extra four than a
special effort to get better gender
representation and we did do that but
unfortunately we didn't fully succeed
for that so women participated at a rate
of between eight and twelve percent in
our survey and unfortunately there are
no global general population numbers
when it comes to software development
but we know from us numbers that women
are represented at about 20 percent in
software development and that's clearly
not what we've achieved here so that is
a clear bias in our survey and it's when
we want to better account for in future
iterations of this but for now we want
to at least acknowledge the bias and we
also asked you that that you take that
into account when interpreting the
results all right that was the
demographic breakdown but what about
actual results so that's further ado
here they are all twenty-eight needs
from biggest frustration to least
frustrating and I want to draw your
attention to the top five and the bottom
five so I'll talk a little bit more
about the top 5 and top 10 in a moment
but when we look at the bottom five
there are some surprises at first glance
in particular number 24 making sites
accessible people have worked on this
know that there are many frustrations
involved with that so why is it ranked
solo and from our interviews we think
it's because accessibility is usually
deprioritized
and developers what
get to spend time on it never notice the
issues that are inherent in that work
and that example should make clear that
context this super important when
interpreting results so this is a
quantitative study you can answer what
and how many by I can't answer why and
that's why we did the in-depth
interviews to get the context which is
also part of our full report let's focus
on the top ten a bit more one thing you
might have noticed is that four of the
top five items are in this similar
bucket its web compatibility and
interoperability one of the biggest
strengths of the web is that there is no
single entity controlling the the
platform but that does not come for free
web developers and designers are
frustrated by not being able to use
features by having to work to find
workarounds for things by having to
fiddle with browser differences and by
the difficulty to verify that something
that works in one browser will not break
in another browser
there is another bucket here though it's
less clear-cut
but it shouldn't be too surprising
especially at this conference the web is
not just the HTML CSS and JavaScript
it's the ecosystem of libraries and
frameworks and tools as well and there
is no standard library for the web there
is no default way to build web
applications on the web and that again
comes with app sites and some very
specific drawbacks that manifest here in
these frustrations documentation and
sample code is almost always a top
priority for web developers and
generally all developers really but
handling multiple frameworks and keeping
up with the ever changing landscape is
something that developers find
frustrating at a very high rate
I mentioned before that one benefit of
large numbers or large number of
participants really is that you can
slice the data and get more useful
results there is one such segmentation
the top top five frustrations between
some of the top countries in the survey
and you will notice that there is very
little variation between those countries
despite those being very different
markets but they all share the same top
frustrations and as you know the space
the pace of change on the web is
incredible so we asked people what their
biggest barrier for entry was when when
it came to new technologies or when when
tech becomes available new tech becomes
available and the results very much they
match the frustrations we talked about
earlier interoperability and
documentation are the leading issues
when it comes to why people might not
jump on some new tech there is something
to keep in mind and so far we've talked
about what is available and causing
issues but we were equally interested in
what it is that people felt was missing
from the web so we asked what are the
things that you would that you would
like to be able to do on the web but
like web platform features today and we
had a massive long tale of of a wish
list as you can see here represented by
the other category with 2% of mention
see each and on the other hand the
biggest category by far is about access
to underlying devices USB Bluetooth
camera
SMS and all kinds of sensors we broke
out access to the file system as its own
category that you can see here as the
biggest request within that larger
access to art per category and then a
similar vein developers want access to
native api's so for contact lists
calendars and other
features of the underlying operating
system and of course you will notice
once again browser compatibility is very
high on the wish list because what good
is a feature that is standardized and
shipped in a browser if you can't use it
because it doesn't reach that threshold
of availability so I know that this was
a bit bleak so before we finish I have
some good news we wanted to have one
measure that would help us understand
what the current sentiment is among web
developers and designers so we asked how
would you rate your overall satisfaction
of the web as a platform and set of
tools to enable you to build or gen8 or
want and a full 76% or either satisfied
or very satisfied and only 9% are
dissatisfied or very dissatisfied so
well there is room to grow the web is
really an amazing platform indeed and by
understanding what what what developers
and designers spend their time on and
identifying the biggest frustrations we
can focus our attention on those and
help make things even better than they
are today which is what I'm very happy
to share some of the responses we got
from browser vendors in response to the
survey so Google came out with a very
strong endorsement and I want to thank
the team for that we said the Google web
platform team is now using developer
satisfaction that's the measure from
just before that they're using that as
one of our top level success metric we
were excited to be using the NDI web
PNAS one of the main sources of data to
help us understand and prioritize the
key areas of developer frustration we
shirt we shared an earlier version of
this report at T pack in September and
was very well-received by the w3c which
makes me very hopeful and not
surprisingly Mozilla is on board as well
and what they said was in the Firefox
team we are always listening to our
his needs in order to make to make
product decisions and the comprehensive
overview of the developer community's
needs
provided by the MV and DNA report is
therefore absolutely essential to us and
we are already incorporating his
findings in our plans so what I just
presented and much more will be in the
full report that we intend to publish
this year still you know it's already
the 12th but very soon and we will make
it freely available to everyone I want
to thank all of our product advisory
board members for their support here and
we invite everyone to use the results to
shape their roadmaps to better reflect
the needs and pain points of developers
and what developers expresses their
frustrations but as I said we want this
to be an annual thing so the next
iteration will start in March 2020 we
will feel the survey in May we will
publish the results in September 20 2000
full in time for TPACK 2020 and the 2021
planning season and with that well we'll
see
[Applause]